[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 78 nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv78
nous sommes le lundi 9 septembre 9
octobre pardon voici les
titres les affrontements se poursuivent
entre Israël et la branche armée du
Hamas le conflit a déjà fait plus de
1200 morts et bien que les combats se
déroulent près de 5000 km des ivelines
la guerre fait réagir également sur le
territoire comment les ivelinois de
confession juifes vivent-ils les
événements interview à suivre dans
quelques jours ils prendront la route du
Maroc à bord de plusieurs Peugeot 205
l'association de poissie un volant pour
205 sourire va distribuer des
fournitures scolaires dans les régions
reculées du pays certaines ont été
touchées par le puissant séisme qui a
frappé l'Ouest marocain il y a un mois
rencontre avec un prodige de sa
discipline à 16 ans thibo lagagel est
déjà double double champion de France de
wakebard double champion de France
junior après les Championnats d'Europe
en septembre livelinois prépare
désormais les Mondiaux qui se
dérouleront l'été prochain au Portugal
nous l'avons suivi au cours d'un
entraînement sur la scène et puis lui
prendra la mer fin octobre depuis le
port du Havre cap sur la Martinique
Louis Burton va participer à sa 7e
transj Vabre la course transatlantique
en duo à bord du bateau bureau Vallé le
skiper de Rambouillet fera équipe une
nouvelle fois avec Davy Baudard quels
sont ses objectifs interview dans les
invit é du 78 en 2è partie d'émission et
c'est d'ailleurs vous qui l'avez
interrogé Michel Mido bonsoir bonsoir
alors on se souvient que la dernière
fois il avait été contraint à l'in
Bandon c'était en 2021 est-ce qu'il est
prêt Louis Burton ah je l'espère en tout
cas c'est ce qui nous a affirmé lors de
cette conférence de presse il est prêt à
partir au large avec son ami de toujours
Davy baudar qui est son ami breton et
tous les deux il pense faire peut-être
un top 10 d'ici d'ici la fin de cette
transat et tout à l'heure on va voir
avec vous également l'actualité sportive
de de ce lundi 9 octobre et non lundi 9
septembre comme je l'ai dit en début
d'émission il y a quoi à retenir dans
l'actualité sportive des Ilin la
première victoire de Versailles en
football les Versaillais ont remporté
une première victoire à domicile dans le
championnat de National dans ce match
ils ont remporté ce match 3 à 2 contre
Cholet et il y aura également des
défaites malheureusement les défaites
pour morpa il y aura également des morpa
en football il y aura également des
défaites en en bal en National 2 restez
avec nous ce sera tout à l'heure dans la
partie sport du
78 mais d'abord les affrontements en
Israël et dans la bande de Gaza samedi
la branche armée du Hamas a attaqué
l'État hébreu et a depuis qui a depuis
largement répliqué un affrontement qui a
fait plus de 1200 morts dans les deux
camps et plus de 700 côté israélien le
Rabin Mendel nisembum du BES lubavic de
50 ans Niel nous donne son sentiment sur
ce conflit et parle des actions menées
par son association il a été interrogé
par Julien Leroi
on a été un peu sous le choc d'autant
plus que c'est samedi c'est c'est le
jour du Shabbat où on n pas de connexion
au médias direct et le lendemain
dimanche était jour de fête qui conclut
les dernières
fêtes fête très joyeuse la conclusion de
la Torah et cetera V information
c'està-dire on a pu réellement
s'informer de tout ce qui était a été
qui hier soir lors de la sorti la
fite nous avons évidemment des euh des
des personnes en Israël que nous
connaissons et des associations avec qui
nous sommes en contact et donc
évidemment ils nous ont envoyé leur
demande et leur besoin et nous sommes
déjà en train de mettre une collecte en
route pour pouvoir les aider voir
qu'est-ce qui est nécessaire comment
faire surtout pour les aider et bien sûr
avec toute la solidarité la solidarité
que nous avons avec les communautés d'
Israël
[Musique]
sur Montini pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de crainte et depuis que nous sommes
installés ici tout s toujours bien passé
néanmoins bien sûr sont des choses
puisque on ne sait pas qu'est-ce qu'il
peut avoir dans les dans les têtes des
uns et des autres malheureusement
et évidemment il faut que que tout reste
dans l'ordre donc une inquiétude je peux
pas dire qu'il n'y en a pas mais en même
temps il continuer notre vie normale
évidemment les enfants continueront à
aller dans les écoles ça il n'y a pas de
[Musique]
souci au chapitre solidarité cette
action menée par l'association un volant
pour 205 sourires le 19 octobre prochain
plusieurs Peugeot 205 rejoindront le
Maroc à bord des fournitures scolaires
qui seront distribuées dans les régions
reculées du pays début septembre
certaines de ces zones à l'ouest du
Maroc ont été frappées par un violent
séisme à quelques le jour du grand
départ nous avons rencontré les pilotes
en en pleine préparation Gabriel Gontier
et Mathilde
Francou c'est un moment un peu
particulier pour Emmanuel Rollin et
Arnaud Cormier dans quelques jours ces
deux ivelinois prendront la route avec
leur Peugeot 205 direction le Maroc pour
un projet humanitaire mais si la
carrosserie du véhicule est flamban
neuve à l'intérieur tout reste à faire
dans notre projet on a des passages de
dune et pour les passages de Dune il
faut qu'on puisse dégonfler les roues il
faut qu'on puisse dégonfler jusqu'à zé
0,5 barres et inversement forcément qu
on revient sur les pistes on regonfle à
deux barres donc on a un système avec un
compresseur à l'intérieur de la voiture
qui nous permet de de gérer le gonflage
des pneus pour permettre ça on a des
pièces sur ce flexible qui est relié à
notre compresseur et qui va être relié
directement au rou des manœuvres
mécaniques bien spécifiques pour un
trajet qui est tout autant notre projet
c'est de participer à une organisation
qui s'appelle le dusterice qui est une
organisation sociale pour aller
distribuer des fournitures scolaires
dans des villas
au fin fond de l'Atlas au Maroc je dis
bien au fin fond de l'Atlas parce queon
est vraiment dans le sud du Maroc dans
les montagnes si le projet était prévu
bien avant le séisme au Maroc
l'association a réorganisé son trajet
pour s'approcher des zones sinistrées
l'organisation dera a déjà fait la
semaine dernière l'intégralité du tracé
en terme de sécurité tout est tout a été
validé grâce à la solidarité des
ivelinois et des entreprises locales le
véhicule a pu être rénové concrétisation
de plusieurs mois de travail pour ses
passionnés d'automobile avoir un but
social de pouvoir mélanger ça avec aussi
un goût de l'aventure d'aller faire des
dunes dans le désert c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez sympathique à
faire départ prévu le 19 octobre si vous
aussi vous souhaitez participer à ce
projet l'association est toujours à la
recherche de dons le point présent sur
le reste de l'actualité dans les
ivlines
avec vous Michel elmidoro et on débute
avec le chiffre du jour 324 324 jours
nous sépare de l'ouverture des Jeux
paralympiques de Paris 2024 et ce lundi
la biillatterterie de l'événement qui se
tient du 28 août au 8 septembre 2024 a
ouvert officiellement depuis ce matin
2,8 millions de billets sont en vente
mais attention cette fois-ci pas de
tirage au sort première arrivée premier
servis chaque acheteur pourra se
procurer jusqu'à 30 billets dans les
ibis les épreuves de paréquitation
auront lieu au Château de Versailles le
par cyclisme sur piste se déroulera au
Vélodrome national oui quelquesunes des
images des derniers Mondiaux de
paracyclisme sur piste qui s'était
déroulé l'année dernière au Vélodrome
national des communes ivlinoises placé
Michel en état de catastrophe naturelle
elles sont au nombre de 5 il s'agit des
communes d'andrésie des loges en Josas
de saint-cer l'école de joeir
Pontchartrin et de boissimau voisin
reconnu donc en état de catastrophe
naturelle au titre de la sécheresse
survenue entre le printemps et l'été
dernier l'arrêté au Journal officiel a
été publié le 4 octobre depuis cette
date les habitants concernés par des
dégradations de leurs bien ont 30 jours
pour déclarer leur sinistrre auprès de
leurs assureurs c'est lancé du côté de
l'Université de Versailles 550 an
Yveline l'événement c'est les semaine de
sensibilisation à l'alimentation et
l'agriculture durable oui et c'est
jusqu'au 20 octobre au programme
sensibilisation au gaspillage projection
d'un documentaire sur le thème de
l'engagement environnemental ou encore
un escape game sur les défis du
recyclage depuis le début du mois le cru
propose aussi deux plats végétariens sur
les à trois plats du jour dans les
restaurants universitaires les mardis et
les jeudis et si vous aussi prês de chez
vous comme d'habitude vous êtes témoin
d'une information qui vous fait réagir
n'hésitez pas à la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
[Musique]
news on poursuit avec l'actualité
sportive dans le département Michel et
et elle est riche on va débuter
justement par du football ont joué ce
weekend dans le championnat de D1 à de
district moropa s'est fait corriger sur
son terrain par bayinoisi le score 4 à1
des images de Régine ralche un match à
oublié pour la S morpa en difficulté
dans le championnat de D1 de district
les morpasiens n'ont pas réussi à
rebondir pour accrocher leur première
victoire de la saison ils se sont
largement inclinés à domicile contre
bayinoisi l'un des favoris à la monté le
score 4 à1 à la fin du
match début de match un petit peu
difficile on encasse de buts dans les 20
premières minutes je pense sur des
petites fautes d'inattention ensuite
voilà on arrive à faire plus ou moins
jeux égal on a quelques occasions à part
la suite avec lesquels on pourrait
revenir dans le match assez facilement
je pense mais voilà on arrive pas à les
mettre au fond à les concrétiser et
derrière défaite en championnat après ce
résultat bayinoisi est 3e et morpas
s'enfonce au classement les morpasiens
sont dernier avec un bilan de trois
défaites en TR matchs avec 15 buts
encaissés les dirigeants semblent tout
de même confiant malgré ce début de
saison compliqué du club c'est une phase
de reconstruction donc ça va se
construire tranquillement il va y avoir
un esprit d'équipe qui va venir et puis
ça ça passera mieux pour la la suite du
championnat on est assez confiant
là-dessus avoir ce premier résultat
accrocher ce premier résultat voilà à
domicile ou à l'extérieur c'est très
important et je pense que sur la suite
ça continuera et derrière on aura une
bonne surprise à la fin de la saison la
prochaine journée de D1 de district est
programmée le dimanche 22 Octobre morpa
se rendra sur la pelouse d'ardricour et
bayinoisi recevra les
Mureaux et on souhaite bien évidemment
bon courage et bonne saison à morpa et
bahinoisis on continue par du football
on monte de quelques cran direction la
nationale Versailles ortter sa première
victoire de la saison à domicile dans le
championnat de National les Versaillais
se sont imposés contre Chol et ce samedi
le score 3-2 les buteurs evinois MDI
balouge pour un doublé et check Djibril
Bangoura en fin de match avec cette
victoire les joueurs de la cité royale
grimpent à la 8e place du classement
victoire on espère qu'il en amènera bien
d'autres dans ce championnat de de
national on continue avec Duran bal dans
le championnat de National 2 l'équipe
féminine de Montini le bretonux s'est
incliné 31 28 ce samedi contre alfville
lors de la 5e journée du championnat une
défaite qui qui n'arrange pas les in
monontaines elle pointe à la 7e place du
classement et surtout l'équipe est à 5
points des premiers rosè Saint-Julien et
Alforville prochain match le 22 octobre
sur le terrain de l'hum Lille le rugby
juste avant de parler de la Coupe du
Monde on continue dans les championnats
régionaux et notamment en régional 1 ce
weekend l'ancienne division d'honneur
c'était un mauvais weekend pour l'Union
rugby centre 78 plus communément appelé
l'URC à 78 les ivinois se sont inclinés
sur leur terrain 33 à 13 face à Parisi
cette deuxè défaite de la saison
concédée en deux matchs n'arrange pas
les joueurs cinquantinois il se retrouve
à la dernière place du classement la
Coupe du monde de rugby et le futur
adversaire des Bleus s'entraîne
justement dans les ivlines oui c'est la
commune de Croatie sur scène qui va
accueillir l'équipe d'Afrique du Sud à
l'occasion de cette coupe du monde de
rugby le futur adversaire des Bleus va
s'entraîner sur le terrain municipal
avant son quart de finale un premier
entraînement est déjà programmé pour ce
mardi dans la commune pour se préparer
pour le match dimanche soir à 21h la
ville de Croatie sur scène a déjà
accueilli une équipe de ce Mondial
c'était Grégory c'était la Tongas tong
le Pay de Gal du côté de Versailles
exactement éliminé en face de poule les
voà qui quit oui le et le Pay de Gal qui
se rendra dans le sud pour la suite de
sa coupe du monde VO donc lesvin
toujours au cœur de cette coupe du monde
de rugby avec maintenant un mot de jeux
olympiques c'est ça à moins c'est ça
exactement à moins d'un an des Jeux
olympiques de Paris les travaux dans le
parc du château de Versailles viennent
de débuter sur le site le sol sera dans
un premier temps àlani avec de la terre
qui sera enlevé dans un second temps des
installations seront montées sur le
périmètre le château de Versailles va
accueillir les épreuves d'quit ation
avec 40000 personnes sur site pour le
cross country il y aura aussi les
épreuves de pentathlon modne pour les
Jeux paralympiques le site va également
accueillir les épreuves de Para
équitation pour terminer ces actualités
sportives on prend la direction de bu en
cours c'est officiel la piste
d'athlétisme du stade Maurice Bak a été
officiellement inauguré ce samedi 7
octobre après plusieurs mois de travaux
ces travaux portés sur la réflection des
aires de compétition et des couloirs les
éclairage ont également été repensé le
coût total des travaux 1,8 million
d'euros financé par le département et
qutin en Iline on écoute la réaction du
maire de la commune on est absolument
ravi parce que les habitants de la ville
ont pu voir tout le processus de
remplacement de cette piste c'était très
spectaculaire puisqu'on a pu avoir
d'abord le remplacement de la piste mais
aussi par exemple des des éclairages
avec l'éclairage l'arrivée des m par
hélicoptère des choses comme ça donc ça
a été vraiment une vraie animation dans
toute la ville de guuencour et
aujourd'hui on envoit le résultat elle
est très belle tout le monde nous le dit
elle est également très fonctionnelle ce
sont les spécialistes qui pour le coup
le disent donc on est vraiment très
heureux ce matin vous nous proposez à
présent une rencontre Michel on parle de
wbard un sport qui sent bon l'été alors
c'est bizarre de dire ça un uf octobre
mais en ce moment on a une météo plutôt
clémente oui on va dire ça ça fait
affaire cette discipline pas si simple
où on est à tracté par un bateau et on
doit réaliser des figures dans les
ibines il y a un sportif qui excelle
dans cette discipline son nom thibo la
Gel son portrait par Louis Douchin
l'espoir du wboard français est iinois
Tibo laagel a seulement 16 ans et se
lance dans le sport de glisse il y a 2
ans ce sportif originaire de Vau sur
scène a découvert cette discipline à
l'âge de 14 ans c'est grâce à son père
que va naître cette passion c'est c'est
grâce à lui que j'ai ce bateau pour
m'entraîner il me suit partout il il
m'accompagne par exemple au championnat
du monde cette année au Portugal il a
tout organisé il s'occupe un peu de tout
quoi depuis sa progression est
fulgurante son palmarès grandit d'années
en année en seulement 2 ans il gagne le
championnat de France deux fois d'affilé
il y a 3 ans je me disais pas champion
de France et encore moins une deuxème
année de plus participer au championnat
du monde participer au championnat
d'Europe avec l'équipe de France ça fait
beaucoup de choses en si peu de temps
grâce à ces titres la Fédération
Française de wakebard le sélectionne en
équipe de France une nouvelle marche
franchie dans sa carrière j'étais très
content je m'y attendais pas forcément
je vais tout faire pour pour montrer
queils m'ont pas sélectionné pour rien
même si sa carrière semble toute tracée
l'ivelinois reste prudent il se laisse 2
ans pour évoluer après son bac en poche
l'objectif sera de re re jooindre la
ville d'Orlando en Floride pour
continuer son apprentissage et pourquoi
pas tenter une carrière professionnelle
et accomplir ses plus grands rêves c'est
de participer au pro WB tour en Floride
et au double up au double up Red Bull
Parks ça peut être possible en fonction
de mes deux années de
progression d'ici là Tibo Lagel va
participer à plusieurs compétitions il
disputera le 30 octobre prochain
jusqu'au 5 novembre les championnats
d'Europe de en
[Musique]
Sicile pour terminer Michel un
rendez-vous un te break gourmand un
événement sportif et culinaire est
organisé ce mardi 10 octobre au golf de
550 anine on écoute l'organisatrice de
l'événement Véronique Chapelin au micro
de
[Musique]
tv78 c'est un événement qui rassemble
des sportifs de haut niveau et des chef
cuisinier donc voilà pour les amoureux
des enfants pour SOS gazelle du sport et
et les
gourmand la compète de golf en scrumble
à4 donc une formule sympathique par
équipe à 11h ils sont partis pour 5h de
de rigolade de jeux avec l'esprit
compétition puisqu'il y a toujours ce
titre de champion des champions et à 16h
le concours Top Chef gourmand donc les
18 équipes de sportifs sont à table avec
leur toc et leur tablier et ils vont
composer les aperro food et les
accompagnement du dîner avec évidemment
un jury de chef qui
sera sans pitié des grands
chefs notre programme depuis 3 ans pour
les enfants c'est vers Paris 2024
c'est-à-dire que depuis 3 ans on suit
les enfants pour les emmener à
l'esprit du sport mais du sport aussi
qui apporte des valeurs humaines parce
que tous les enfants ne peuvent pas être
des Champions mais l'exemple des
Champions est extraordinaire les enfants
viennent des
Yvelines le matin et ensuite il y
aura trois classes de 30 élèves donc 90
[Musique]
enfants merci Michel pour toutes ces
actualités on va jeter à présent un coup
d'œil aux prévisions météo de
demain grand soleil demain matin dans
les Yvelines avec des températures
moyennes de 12°gr il fera plus chaud du
côté de Versailles avec 14°gr prévu et
ce n'est pas une erreur nous serons bien
demain le mardi 10 octobre il fera dans
l'après-midi jusqu'à 28°r dans le
département cette météo estival devrait
se poursuivre jusqu'à vendredi ce mardi
10 octobre nous fêterons les giselins
tout de suite les invités du 78 avec
vous Michel
[Musique]
Mido la conférence de presse de la
Transa Jacques Vabre 2023 vient tout
juste de se terminer deux équipages
iinois seront au départ de l'épreuve il
y aura notamment Louis Burton et David
baudar qui seront sur cette transat
jacqu Vabre 2023 Louis Burton qui est
rambolitin et did budar qui vient un peu
plus loin par contre alors Louis Burton
qu'est-ce que ça fait d'être sur cette
7e trans Java personnellement ben
bonjour à tous c'est un rêve qui se
réalise une fois de plus prendre le
départ des courses c'est déjà une grande
aventure parce qu'on a des bateaux très
compliqués il faut se préparer se
qualifier puis je pars avec di qui est
un grand champion et et en plus un ami
donc voilà ça va être un moment un
moment formidable et puis on peut relier
rambouiller la Bretagne voilà on en est
la preuve vivante Davy ça vous fait quoi
de partir pour la troisème fois avec
Louis Burton
et bien euh je suis très heureux que
Louis m'accorde une fois de plus sa
confiance lui et toute l'équipe B Racing
ainsi que buauvallé et euh moi j'adore
naviguer avec lui j'arrête pas de lui
dire c'est mon binôme au-delà de de
l'aventure sportive il y a l'aventure
humaine et euh je crois qu'on est pas
mal sur ce niveau-là alors vous allez
partir sur bureau Vallé i comment il est
le bateau ben c'est un bateau assez
récent puisque c'est un bateau qui date
de 2020 juste avant le précédent vend
des globes
là au défi azimut le bateau était encore
4e à 1 seconde au niveau vitesse des des
trois premiers donc c'est un bateau qui
reste d'actualité qui a été amélioré cet
hiver sur lequel on va mettre des voiles
neuves et retailler et repenser suite à
l'expérience qu'on a avec le bateau donc
voilà c'est c'est sûr qu'avec 40 40 duo
une dizaine de bateau neuf ça va ça va
être très engagé sportivement mais mais
on a encore de quoi jouer devant du coup
cette course transatlantique on l'a
compris se dispute en duo quelles sont
les clés pour pas se marcher dessus
peut-être dans le
bateau en fait c'est assez simple moi je
m'occupe de de tout le bateau dehors et
puis Louis à l'intérieur il gère il gère
il gère la navigation non en fait en
course en double sur ce genre de bateau
c'est avant tout deux solitaires on
passe un peu de temps tous les deux mais
on est à beaucoup de moments on est tout
seul on gère le bateau et les bateaux
sont quand même assez grands pour pas se
marcher dessus et euh
ça se passe très bien en fait
oui tu confirmes il a une bonne
répartition des rôles au sein du bateau
ouais c'est un gros avantage he de bien
se connaître d'avoir beaucoup naviguer
ensemble avec des viis quand l'un se
repose il faut quand même bien sûr être
capable de gérer le bateau complètement
et le côté agréable c'est d'essayer de
faire les choses en commun au maximum
donc si desvis s'occupe de la météo et
de la stratégie il m'en parle si c'est
moi qui m'en occupe je lui en parle et
on essaie de prendre les décisions
ensemble et puis après parfois aussi en
fonction du feeling il y en a un qui va
vouloir attaquer plus que l'autre et
cetera donc voilà il faut réussir à être
dans le dialogue au maximum pas être
chacun dans son coin et c'est aussi ça
bien s'entendre sur une jacvabre et ça
peut grâce à ça faire parfois des des
étincelles alors on le rappelle C
transat JAC VAB se déroule entre Le
Havre et la Martinique quels sont les
pièges à éviter sur cette course
transatlantique alors le départ du Havre
c'est déjà un endroit compliqué c'est
assez reculé dans la Manche donc à cette
période ben on a des dépressions qui qui
arrivent de l'Atlantique qui peuvent
boucher un petit peu la la sortie de la
Manche c'est étroit donc là il y a des
cargos des bateaux de pêche du courant
très fort donc ça c'est un gros piège
déjà il peut se passer plein de choses
on avait eu des déboirs d'ailleurs dans
cette zone il y a 2 ans la sortie du
golf de démattage ouais avec un
démattage tout à fait sortie du golf de
Gascogne zone compliquée aussi parce que
bah il y a les systèmes météo viennent
et ben s quiill est comme ça entre la
France et l'Espagne donc c'est un peu
bloquant puis après une fois qu'on est
sorti de là on arrive dans la Lisée plus
ou moins vite donc là on est poussé par
le vent et puis là ils nous font faire
une petite blague ils nous font
descendre un peu dans le poteau noir
donc la zone où le vent est pas très
clair et et on va rester un peu dedans
et puis après il faut qu'on ressorte
dans l'Ouest et qu'on arrive à retourner
la Martinique vers la Martinique pardon
donc ça c'est un ouais c'est un défi de
réussir à ce que ça se passe bien dans
cette zone là là normalement il va se
passer pas mal de choses j'imagine Dav
qu'il faudra bien communiquer à C dans
ces moments clés euh bien sûr en fait
même bien analysé en amont euh toutes
ces phases prédépart la première semaine
qui va être sûrement la plus compliquée
l'arrivée sur le poteau noir la fin de
course au portant en arrivant sur la
Martinique non il faut anticiper on
communiquera forcément beaucoup tous les
deux et deux cerveaux sont beaucoup plus
fort qu'un seul donc on prendra
forcément les bonnes décisions si je me
trompe pas Louis tu as fait au mieux 5e
sur cette transat Jack VAB est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir un objectif de podium cette
année ou de victoire alors on est on est
dans une philosophie euh complètement
différente il faut avoir en tête que
quand je termine 5e de la Jacques Vabre
il y avait 15 bateaux au départ là on va
être 40 bateaux au départ il y a
beaucoup de plus de bateaux neufs et on
est aussi dans une perspective de de de
d'approche du vent des globes et sur
laquelle on travaille déjà depuis depuis
plusieurs années avec desvis et avec le
reste de l'équipe bureau Vallé donc on
veut essayer d'être le plus performant
possible mais on veut avant tout
terminer la course c'est très important
quelques jours après l'arrivée de la
jacevabre il va y avoir une autre course
qui va repartir dans l'autre sens qui
est très importante aussi dans le cadre
de la préparation au vent des globes
donc grosso modo on va mettre plein gaz
mais on va essayer de savoir lever le
pied quand il faudra oui ça sera
l'occasion aussi de tester encore une
nouvelle fois ton bateau j'imagine ouais
là là on en est plus au stade du test on
en est stade de fiabiliser et et d'être
sûr en effet que les décisions les choix
qu'on a pu prendre sont les bons dans un
an on est on sera au départ du v des
globes donc voilà maintenant faut être
sûr et vent des globes forcément c'est
un objectif ouais le vent des globes
c'est c'est un objectif important dans
la classe Soka c'est c'est hyper
important ça l' proportionnellement
moins manière moins impressionnante
qu'avant parce que toutes les autres
courses sont tirées vers le haut avec
beaucoup de participants mais oui le
tour du monde ça reste un objectif très
important sportivement et puis pour les
partenaires pour toute la vie du projet
mais avant ce V des Glob il y a cette
transat ja qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter à tous les deux avant de de
prendre le départ
euh du plaisir beaucoup et
euh et qu'on arrive en bonne forme de
l're côté en bonne forme et pas trop
loin de des premiers ce serait pas mal
merci à tous les deux la Transat jackvab
2023 le départ sera donné le 29 octobre
depuis Le Havre bon il s'est pas trop
mouillé sur les pronostics Louis Burton
on peut quand même espérer pour lui au
moins top 5 un top 5 oui c'est ce qu'il
m'a dit après l'interview il espère un
top 5 mais on ne sait jamais en mer
comme on l'a pu le voir sur les
dernières éditions il a eu il a eu deux
démattages sur les deux dernières
grosses compétitions de voile donc on ne
sait jamais c'est la mer bon ce sera
l'occasion de préparer le vend Glub 2024
on se souvient la dernière édition il
avait terminé à la 3e place Louis Burton
juste pour citer parmi les 190 keipers
en liste il y a un autre ivelinois c'est
Éric bon et on l'interviewerera un peu
plus tard dans le mois juste avant la
Transat oui juste avant la Transat du
coup la transat Jacques VAP qui parti le
29 octobre depuis Le Havre Éric Bellon
un versaillais qui sera avec son projet
comme un seul homme qui est devenu
anglais qui s'appelle maintenant stand
as one et il aura pour objectif
également de faire un top 10 parce qu'il
participera au vent des globes 2024 en
concurrence il sera en concurrence avec
Louis Burton on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler d'ici le départ de cette
transat ja vous l'avez dit ce sera le 29
octobre depuis le le porort du HAV merci
beaucoup Michel elmidoro pour toutes ces
précisions et c'est la fin du 78 merci
de votre fidèle dans un instant sur tv78
à la découverte des evvelines belle
soirée à
[Musique]
tous